[Musique]
Il a dit
c'est comme ça
C'était nouveau
versions de curieux
et
[des rires]
vous apprenez
et aussi au peuple
Oui
est
nous nous sommes retrouvés avec une crise des permis
un
jour
as
Oui
est de manger
oui c'est tout
bon
cette mission
publicité
m
nous pensons
et la passion
déjà
Je ne sais pas. Non
séché
et je sais sec
Oui
ensuite
pourquoi ne commences-tu pas à danser
même
c'est qu'il utilise
- séance de travail yolanda
bien papier
et
ef
comme si j'avais vécu
ce serait une nouvelle qui est fausse je sais avec
combien de temps puis-je respirer
Monsieur
J'ai suivi
il est aussi temps
Oui
si tu fais partie de l'équipe
Oh
et aussi un manoir
regarde garçon
[Musique]
Fernandez
Oui
brille
le A
et donné les conseils comme il se doit
la sixième ville commence ou steak
cela serait
je sens que je suis plein
si seulement
et moi
eh bien, quel éclat
mais tu dois être
et innovation
la couleur de votre pilote
et sept cas
le chapeau fait son chemin
rappeler
Oui
avec un mythe
appelle-moi
session fais-le dit
Oui oui
par la réglementation des buts
c'est ainsi que nous savons comment ils ont été vaincus
ou
allons-y les titres
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi pour moi
je
tout ça
a été
mais pour ça
ensuite
et ange
à
pas de substitut
Oui
maintenant j'ai acquis la ville j'étais extatique
vin
pour
et puis nous allons
Oh
merci exceptionnellement
et fonctionnent car ils sont propres
un
pour notre communauté
et écrire
et si
où que tu sois
alors vélez
Oui
où
apollinaire ou site
Alors
ré
nous allons avoir
bien
nous avons j'ai dit au revoir c'est un oui je le fais
voir cette entité
Oui
elles ou ils
[Musique]
deux
oui c'était ok
Oui
est
J'ai alors opté pour un jean
[Applaudissements]